OK. Let's try our caller from the 6 0 7 area
code. Who's calling today from 6 0 7 8 a.m.
here? Yes, I can. You're coming in so loud,
just pull the phone a little bit away from
your mouth and then I think we'll be able
to hear you much better.
Gotcha. How's that? It's marginally better,
but I would keep going. What's going on?
Not much. I have two questions to begin. First
one, I started making short of sweet only
recently, then becoming politically literate
to the likes of, you know, you and kalika
Lenski back in 2016 from Hillary, all that.
So these days when you try to research, all
you get is his, you know, his recent briefings
and press conferences. So it's curious if
even if I can get your perspective on why
he seems to be so hated. I'm from upstate
New York. I wonder if it's a Second Amendment
thing or if there's more that I haven't research.
Obviously, I'm still I have no idea why. Why
rural New York upstaters would hate Andrew
Cuomo. I mean, I know that on the left there's
a contingent that doesn't like him because
he's not really that progressive. I mean,
he's a pretty he you know, he's a pretty centrist
Democrat. And on fiscal issues in the state
of New York. Yeah. He doesn't have any particularly
progressive record. So I think that I I couldn't
tell you about the gun people in upstate New
York. But overall, the left the left left
isn't thrilled with him because they feel
that the good press he's getting around handling
of Corona virus ignores the fact that he has
a very, very centrist, moderate fiscal record
in the state of New York.
Yes, absolutely, that makes sense. And I was
also curious if you could also get your perspective
on where you think Andrew Yang's future might
hold for him. I liked him initially. You know,
Edward, don't get the bag. It's hilarious.
But he does have some other policies I like.
And I do like the fact that he's he's not
a politician. But now I feel like he's you
know, he's thinking about running for mayor,
I believe, and he's working for CNN and all
that. So I was curious if you think that's
going to benefit him or maybe he should maybe
you should get that experience or if you should
continue trying to be.
I have absolutely no advice whatsoever for
Andrew Yang. I mean, listen. On the popularity
and following that he built, he probably would
be able to find a congressional seat to run
for and have a really good shot. He could
probably have a shot at, you know, maybe someday
at a Senate seat might require him, you know,
maybe maybe to move to a different state potentially.
But know he's built a following that would
allow him to raise money and likely do very
well for a number of different positions.
But I have no advice and I've not heard anything
about his aspirations.
So I wouldn't be able to say I'm going to
let you go because that that that you're just
so right on your phone that it's crinkling
and crunching. We're going to take a quick
break. If you are holding, don't hang up,
too, because I will be going right back to
the phones momentarily.